I don't think I've ever written a letter
the last time I wrote a letter was in
second grade when we had pen pals
the last letter I wrote was to Santa
Claus I'm writing a letter to my dad's
boyfriend to my sister to my grandma
ahem here we go dear sister
[Music]
this is definitely hard I'm in my head I
can't get out my head I don't remember
how to write letters what are you saying
[Music]
thank God it is over I'm never reading a
letter again this might be a cute thing
that I could do with my grandma
definitely there's so much that came up
for me when I wrote this letter that I
would I don't think would have come up
if I was texting him sharing why he
means so much to me and how much he's
changed my life in the past five years
that gets emotional it's hard to address
how you really feel about somebody and
how much someone means to you until you
sit down and you don't have your cell
phone you don't have any media there's
nothing and you're just with a pen and
paper
[Music]
you